it's April it's day one of 30 of the new
30 days to stop the spread the new
shutdown of the u.s. and states that are
participating I'll update you daily on
the numbers for the time being official
coronavirus death toll globally as of
this morning eight hundred and seventy
six thousand the official death toll
forty three thousand five thirty three
in the US we officially have over one
hundred and eighty eight thousand cases
and four thousand fifty nine deaths the
latest modeling from IH m e expects the
u.s. death toll to be ninety three
thousand seven hundred sixty five that's
updated daily based on actual case data
it will be a difficult month we knew
they would do it and now it's starting
the next war or battle lines on the
disinformation propaganda that is being
spread from the fact list rumpus right
is to claim that the coronavirus death
toll is fake now what's amazing or maybe
not is that there is a real story about
an inaccurate coronavirus death toll but
the story is that the real death toll is
probably higher than the official
account not lower but I'll get to that
in a second let's go through first
what's being said so that we all
understand this first we had no cases
and because we weren't testing Donald
Trump bragged we continued to have few
cases and other countries are starting
to have more cases of course eventually
testing started to ramp up and the case
numbers started to go up and they
started to tell us well our case numbers
are going to increase artificially
quickly because we are doing so much
testing it's still not a reason to be
alarmed
now that's partially true but the case
number which is now closing in closing
it on 200,000 cases in the US it still
under states the real number of cases
because not everybody's getting tested
but one thing you can't fake is the
death toll right which is now around
four thousand the deaths or deaths no
matter how much you are testing right
well maybe or maybe not there's now a
concerted propaganda disinformation
effort to claim that the death toll is
exaggerated how could that possibly be
well they say and I'll show you exactly
who they are in a moment they say that
people are actually dying of other stuff
but doctors are lying and saying it was
coronavirus there's a sort of spectrum
of the level of crazy that different
people are presenting with this but
that's the general idea let's look at
some examples here are diamond and silk
Trump loves these two ladies very very
dangerous propagandists take a look in a
matter of two weeks over a thousand
people supposedly died from corona from
the corona virus in a two weeks time
period over a thousand people after
being tested positive have died from the
corona virus but it took 39 days from
January all the way up to February the
29th I believe for the first person to
die here's another thing come on here's
another thing my president said on March
2 24th Tuesday this past week my
president said that he was loved [ __ ]
America to be back up and running I knew
this was gonna happen
he said there was twenty five thousand
four hundred and eighty nine cases with
three hundred and seven thousand mmm
instantaneously you had the media
calling President Trump out he won't it
open by Easter he won't this open by
Easter me and you were talking I said
now watch the numbers of deaths go up my
watch everything increase because they
wanted to make it want to make it look
bad that's one of our eyes they want to
make it look bad so they are faking the
death numbers imagine their disbelief
how did a thousand people die well it's
three thousand it's four thousand it's
called a virus it grows virally going
viral comes
from this from how quickly it
accelerates that is the whole origin of
the term this act by the way this counts
what I just played for you that counts
as political analysis to some people on
the right Donald Trump himself Don Jr
they love diamond and silk they think
that they're brilliant and this is of
course so disrespectful and disgusting
to the families of the thousands of
people who have died here in the United
States now here's another example this
is right-wing radio host mark levin a
very well known bomb thrower
saying essentially the same thing I mean
questioning that the death toll is
really accurate when you look at the
mortality rate that they say is a direct
result of this virus they say then you
see the percentage of people who die
from the virus going down going down as
you might imagine we've talked about
this last week plus I cannot find
anywhere the definition of what it means
to die from this virus in other words if
I go into the hospital and I already
have a very very bad heart and I'm not
given a whole lot of time then I get
this virus and it puts me over the edge
is that Canada's dying from heart
failure heart disease a heart attack if
you have one or the virus I don't know I
don't know Mark Levin is acting like
this is something unique to the virus
but it's not I mean this is I'll talk to
you in a moment but this is this is an
issue with the flu
this is an issue with AIDS we'll get to
that in a moment here's Bill Mitchell
right wing trumpets radio host who
tweeted how many people are dying from
kovat 19 god only knows literally but
the numbers being reported aren't
accurate so let's talk sense here dr.
Anthony Fauci has addressed this issue
in some recent interviews this is a
respiratory disease if you die from
pneumonia complications and you tested
positive for the virus
that's a corona virus death and it
should be counted as such not for
political purposes but for tracking
purposes for medical purposes for
epidemiology purposes it's pneumonia
caused by coronavirus if you have organ
failure caused by the virus you died of
the virus and that's how it should be
tracked so they are now simply saying
now you can't believe the death toll
it's literal gaslighting now this is an
issue this was an issue and and it still
is to some degree with AIDS this is an
issue of the flu it's not unique to
coronavirus there's always this issue of
I mean listen is someone literally dying
of the flu or are they dying from
pneumonia caused by the flu or a
complication caused by the flu or you
know a blood marker insufficiency caused
by the it's a flu death and there's
always an issue of whether we're
attributing enough deaths to some of
these viruses now let me take the
opportunity to tell you something else
we probably do have an issue about the
number of deaths that's being reported
but the issue is not that we are over
reporting the real issue is we are under
reporting because we know that there are
people dying of presumptive case of
corona virus not all presumptive cases
are being counted sometimes people don't
get tested you can test them post-mortem
to find out if they have the virus but
often it's not being done because the
bodies are literally piling up in tragic
dystopian fashion those should be
counted as coronavirus deaths many of
them are not so if the death toll can't
be trusted it's because it's too low not
because it's too high don't fall for it
don't let them propagate this nonsense
today's program is made possible in part
by our sponser identity guard giving my
audience 33% off when you use the link
underneath this video we talk about data
breaches on the show we talk about them
too often because they happen too often
and a lot of people underestimate how
likely they are to become victims of
identity theft as a result of these
breaches that take place and it's a
nightmare the average identity theft
victim loses more than 1300 dollars and
six months of their life trying to clean
the mess up it's no joke but what
identity guard
does is monitor the dark web and alert
you anytime your social security number
credit card numbers account numbers or
other personal information are detected
in places where criminals share this
stuff with each other online they also
detect red flags like changes to your
bank accounts or your credit scores and
you'll get an alert as quickly as in a
few seconds if you do become a victim of
identity theft identity guard sets you
up with a dedicated support team who
will take what would normally be a very
stressful situation and turn it into
something as easy as possible to resolve
and you'll be covered for up to a
million dollars of reimbursement for
stolen funds identity guard plans start
at just $8.99 a month but the David
Pakman show audience will instantly get
33% off by using the link underneath
this video you'll also get access to
identity guards browser extension which
protects you from phishing attempts
unsecured websites other types of
attacks just while you're browsing
around online it takes just a few
minutes to set up an account you give
them a few pieces of info about yourself
and you're good to go
the identity theft headaches are often
completely avoidable if you have a
service that's protecting you from it
and will help you to deal with it if
something were to happen an identity
guard is the most trusted one out there
it's already affordable but you'll save
an extra 33% when you use my link which
I've put in the description right
underneath this video